اينما تولي وجهك في تل ابيب ستجد هذه
اللافتات التي تطالب بالافراج عن الاسرى
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في غزه حراك بدا
ياخذ منحا جديدا بعد قتل ثلاثه من الاسرى
بنيران الجيش الاسرائيلي في حي الشجاعيه
يوم الجمعه الماضي بعدها تزايدت مخاوف
عائلاتهم من ان يقتلوا على يد الجيش اما
قصفا او برصاص الجن
منذئذ انتقل عدد من عائلات الاسرى وداعم
لهم للاعتصام بشكل دائم عند مدخل مقر
وزاره الدفاع في تل ابيب والهدف زياده
الضغط الشعبي على مجلس الحرب وتحديدا على
رئيس الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو ومطالبته
بالعمل على ابرام صفقه تبادل للافراج عن
الاسرى حتى لو كان ذلك مقابل وقف تام
لاطلاق النار وصفقه تبادل عنوانها الكل
مقابل
الكل الان تغلق عائلات الاسرى المحتجزين
في غزه مدخل مقر وزاره الدفاع في تل ابيب
ضمن هذا الحراك المتواصل من اجل المطالبه
بالافراج عنهم على الفور يغلقون المدخل
لعده دقائق وهي عباره عن عدد من
الثواني التي توازي عدد الاسرى الذين
اسروا في غزه مع بدايه هذه
الحرب الهدف الاسمى حاليا هو اعاده
المختطفين لان قيمه حياه الانسان عاليه
ونحن مجبرون ان نفعل كل شيء عادتهم وبكل
ثمن بعدها علينا الاهتمام بامن اسرائيل كي
نتاكد انه بامكاننا العيش بسلام الى جانب
الغزيين لكن اولا يجب اعاده المختطفين
في ضوء هذه التطورات تزايدت المؤشرات على
احتمال ابرام صفقه جديده لتبادل الاسرى مع
حركه حماس وذكرت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ان
اسرائيل ابدت استعدادها ورغبتها في التوصل
الى صفقه تبادل جديده ضمن منحى للافراج عن
40 اسيرا محتجزا مقابل اسبوع من الهدنه
والافراج عن ثلاثه اضعاف هذا العدد من
الاسرى الفلسطينيين بينهم من المحكيات
العاليه نجوان سمري الجزيره تل ابيب